building the powers belongs to the skies
when the whole thing comes crashing down
don't ask me why don't ask me why
[Music]
[Applause]
you
the Lord today [ __ ] most people
to go on a church it's standing on a
line and Danny's right now
it's a great sermon suck my dick and
call me shorty [ __ ] uncle
Joey's here from the Garden of Good and
Evil this is the garden where he first
starts the first dick ready but let's
put that aside you bad [ __ ]
what do you got you got seven days to
[ __ ] Christmas a week from tonight
you'll be sitting there huh deck the
halls with [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] and
you sit there gone where has my life
done you [ __ ] uncle Joey's here
to shine some light on you today and
tell you it's a beautiful [ __ ]
day to be alive you got the world by the
balls you got nothing to worry about
today's the day you do your little
[ __ ] goals you hang out with the
family and Monday you come out the box
Jack like slick dick Magoo you follow me
anyway we got a podcast tonight I'm not
gonna tell you who you're gonna [ __ ]
love it and beside that that's it and
that's that
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive whether you got snow on the ground
whatever the [ __ ] you got the ground
don't matter
oh it's brutal big you're alive
[ __ ] then all those people
[ __ ] Africa [ __ ] bees and rocks
right now and there you are with a
[ __ ] you know living like a doctor
and you don't even [ __ ] know which
will stop you [ __ ] money all right
that's it the country divided stop your
whining it's the holidays but they
should aside Jill Stein don't rob you
think it all suck you think they're all
a bunch of [ __ ] bloodsuckers anyway
you follow me you want to be a real
[ __ ] American you smoke your reefer
you should loop the flag you pick up
litter you're good to kind [ __ ]
animals and that's it
everything else falls into place dog
believe it or not
thank you for supporting me I'm the
specialist this time Lee it is the
biggest Christmas present him is
government mystic presently you guys are
giving me back yeah I might make a
giggle I say stupid perverted dumb [ __ ]
but yo I love you [ __ ] because
what are you guys I have got you know
that we have to we have each other a lot
of people don't have that we have each
other we have this [ __ ] periscope we
get together we blow by bias
I mean well people paint 200 an hour for
therapy oh [ __ ] it suckers this is our
therapy right here we came together you
say things to me go [ __ ] yourself fat
man or whatever the [ __ ] you saying that
don't matter me that they're dumb I'm
over here spread and [ __ ] love and
you want to say where the [ __ ] who
raised you you [ __ ] Martian anyway
let's switch it up a bit
right after I finish yeah I'm gonna head
over to the weed store and put this
package together and that's it and
that's that brother man you know I'm
saying this how we do it no one no fun
no nothing
we [ __ ] put it together in our heads
we go out there and we do over the
harbour little commitments become big
commitments okay
always remember that a wise man told me
that one day you buy a joint the next
day you buy the panel anyway I gotta
stop with those stupid jokes Joey what
the [ __ ]
totally gonna get you it's not a big day
you run a good technique I do a couple
rounds and I come home I don't kill
myself
tomorrow's the big day you know you got
to go back to the back to back to back
remember I still suck but I go why I
don't know I should just be staying home
minding my business but sometimes you
gotta make yourself a better person but
at the end deep down inside I know I'm a
[ __ ] mutt you follow me that's the
beauty about people that they're [ __ ]
much and they walk around but how I save
the bird the other day I get the [ __ ]
you're a mutt you're mighty have no
decency meanwhile you'll walk around
amongst good white people trying to fit
in your [ __ ] like my ex-wife for example
a dirty [ __ ] [ __ ]
she lives in [ __ ] in Louisville
Lafayette Colorado [ __ ] they live they
parade themselves like that nice white
people but guess what they yank the
child from a guy think about this every
couple days like when I hug my daughter
I go who could turn a kid on a parent
but these guys walk around parade
themselves like they're [ __ ] good
people this Kathy ball wait till she
gets cancer deep deep deep in the inside
of her [ __ ] my rocks are from the
inside up
I don't wish that on it but that's what
happens when you get people rope
somebody does you wrong you could stab
them beat them up at the end who gives a
[ __ ] give them rope say a prayer for
them and light a candle and watch their
[ __ ] rot and fall out I've seen it a
thousand times
for years I wanted establish but guess
what me living it's enough cuz everyday
she gotta walk around look around
because that might be the day I have a
bad day and I decide to put a [ __ ]
knife in my mouth and crawl the Colorado
you follow me but [ __ ] all that noise
that's just that's just to let you know
when my head used to be it but I am when
you've gotta stop and watch it go down
the wall get some business pick up some
reefer and the rest is the rest happy
Holidays to you and your families Happy
Hanukkah to the [ __ ] Jews in
the struggle wander to my black
[ __ ] and that's it everybody
else if you're an atheist suck my dick
you gotta believe in something
why not believe in me Black Sabbath
bloody Sabbath
don't forget Wednesday night the 21st
come Gardens inventory it's a great
little show we just eat little Chinese
food and jump up and down
Thursday night this is not happening
what are we shall fear are you kidding
me or what
and beside that that's it matter that I
love your [ __ ] go spend time
with your family and don't be careless
women and children can be careless men
can't be jealous
vito corleone stay black